welcome to this video playing only X
from turkey played him really often with
not a good score minus one out of eight
games and very very crazy a point
distribution I have one out of five is
white and two out of two is like okay so
i tried a new line here the improved or
deferred standards I don't really know
much about it and I only recently saw a
couple of games which I like but I'm
just playing this but yeah I don't know
exactly how it is done this is one of
the ideas that you actually try to delay
this Bishop is seven moves so that TI
can actually feel and shatter early the
bishop on g7 is very often incorrectly
placed that it's not the bad at all okay
um a form
mmm yeah I would like to play a rookie
aid but 95 versus irritating a bit maybe
just this preventing everything and
preparing rupee aid
yeah it looks like a fairly normal
position from them from the room yeah
this is interesting he does not even
threaten on b5 s is it's a self pin on
the FL
ok Knight e5 or 97 mm yeah probably to
eat 795 looks a bit misplaced yeah the
night on a three it has ideas like going
exactly like going to be for that can be
M can be a real a really good good
option nevertheless i'm going to play
see five year he must take now otherwise
this was totally useless this maneuver
take but take Bishop takes e4 as sir is
under fire okay you heat it does not
take I mean you can try to maneuver this
night but the way exactly no but if he
take special clicks how does it offend
the form there is no good way to do that
I think so instead he decides to blunder
you form or if what exactly is going on
here if I take you for what's the point
95 I just I take on g4
yeah it seems that this is kind of setup
totally irritated too okay let's see is
there some point no I just I just do
that what 94 I can just take it I do it
I don't see the point Nagi who I take it
just is a piece down now okay so if i
return to f6 then there is a form is
this the idea really maybe I can also
place you form let's do that get c5 as a
as a square or I can take I can take a
d5 as well and that's not that's not
ideal I can also take here and take my
resign and now resides yeah I can trick
it to me I can take here I can play nite
nite back yeah 95 is probably the
easiest this is what i originally
intended yeah I don't know what I don't
know what he was thinking that okay
cannot cannot guess yeah after this it's
already slightly tricky here I mean okay
93 Bloods blundering e4 I can he can
play play em somewhat yeah it's in some
small movie Bishop d2 or something the
problem maybe I should have played c6
actually yeah the point is if he does
that before it's very weak I mean maybe
this obviously black has no problems
here but it keeps the material together
yeah this i will just just take it now I
mean nigerians imp lead capture and the
problem is that these two pawns will
also be a under fire and probably form
c4 and even Queen takes d5 so this is
just totally totally lost already yeah
this well I just I just take everything
here the idea i can i can even take it
if i want i mean even this is winning
but 95 is the easiest there is no
compensation whatsoever okay thanks for
watching